BEFORE, AND THE PRESIDENT STILL
ACCOMPLISHED THAT.
WE WILL HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
JOINING US FIRST OUTSIDE THE
ARENA IN ORLANDO, SORRY WE HAVE
TO CUT OUT THE ROLLING STONES.
THERE HE IS, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, THE GUY THAT WE
LOVE, MY FRIEND.
BY THE WAY -- SO I MADE AN
AUDIBLE, LAWRENCE.
AND THE AUDIBLE WAS YOU WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE IN CALIFORNIA.
YOU HAD THIS HORRIBLE EXPERIENCE
THAT YOU TALKED ABOUT YESTERDAY,
RIGHT, ON THIS PROGRAM, AND I'M
STILL ANGRY ABOUT IT.
I SAID, NO, I WANT LAWRENCE TO
GO DOWN TO ORLANDO.
AND I WANT HIM TO MEET OTHER
PEOPLE, NOT AT THE IMPEACH TRUMP
RALLY.
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE, LAWRENCE?
>> Reporter: LOOK AT ALL OF
THESE PEOPLE RIGHT HERE TODAY.
THEY ARE EXCITED ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT, WHAT HE DELIVERED ON.
I GOT SOME NEW FRIEND HERE.
I HAVE SUSAN RIGHT HERE.
SUSAN, TELL OUR AUDIENCE, TELL
SEAN WHAT YOU FEEL LIKE IS THE
NUMBER ONE ACCOMPLISHMENT OF
THIS PRESIDENT.
>> THIS PRESIDENT HAS KEPT HIS
PROMISES TO THE PEOPLE OF THE
UNITED STATES.
WHETHER IT'S POPULAR OR NOT, HE
KEEPS HIS PROMISE.
HE HAS MORE ENERGY.
AND THAT PLACE WAS EXPLOSIVE
TONIGHT.
FULL OF ENTHUSIASM.
AND THE MAN IS LIKE THE EVER
READY BUNNY.
HE JUST KEEPS ON GOING.
GOD BLESS DONALD TRUMP.
>> Reporter: YOU'RE HEARING IT
FOR YOURSELF.
PEOPLE HERE ARE ELECTRIC.
THEY FEEL LIKE THE PRESIDENT
DELIVERED ON HIS PROMISE.
COME HERE, MIKE.
THIS IS A GUY FROM MY COMMUNITY.
HOW DO YOU FEEL LIKE THE
PRESIDENT HAS DELIVERED ON
ISSUES WHEN IT COMES TO BLACK
AMERICA?
>> HONESTLY, AS A BLACK
AMERICAN, I HAVE NEVER SEEN A
PRESIDENT DO SO MUCH FOR OUR
COMMUNITY AS THIS PRESIDENT.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT LOWEST
UNEMPLOYMENT.
YOU GOT PRISON REFORM.
FIRST STEP ACT.
URBAN REVITALIZATION.
THIS PRESIDENT IS DELIVERING ON
HIS PROMISES AND HE'S UNIFYING
THE COUNTRY ON TOP OF THAT.
YOU KNOW, OVER ON THE LEFT, I
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO GO AND SEE
THE ANTI-TRUMP PROTESTING.
IT WAS ALL JUST NEGATIVITY.
THE ENERGY IN THIS ROOM WAS
ELECTRIC AND POSITIVE.
YOU KNOW, CONSERVATIVES CALL ME
PATRIOT, AMERICAN, BROTHER,
LEFTISTS, THEY CALL ME OTHER
THINGS I WILL NOT SAY ON TV.
AS AMERICANS, WE ARE UNITED
UNDER THIS PRESIDENT.
>> Reporter: SEAN, BACK TO YOU
IN NEW YORK.
YOU'RE HEARING IT FROM YOURSELF
FROM THE PATRIOTS HERE RIGHT
HERE.
>> Sean: LAWRENCE, I GOT A
QUESTION FOR YOU.
I KNOW IT'S HARD TO HEAR.
SO WE BECOME GOOD -- WE'VE
BECOME GOOD FRIENDS.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO ADMIT THAT
PUBLICLY.
BUT DO YOU LIKE THE AUDIBLE I
CALLED?
YOU GOT TO BE HONEST.
>> Reporter: I LIKE THE AUDIBLE
THAT YOU CALLED.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN SHOWING
ME LOVE ALL DAY.
WE'VE ALL BEEN IN THE RAIN
TOGETHER, WE SWEATED TOGETHER.
IT WAS GREAT TO MEET PEOPLE FROM
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND THEY LOVE FOX NEWS AND SEAN
HANNITY.
[ CHEERS ]
>> Sean: I WILL SAY THIS,
LAWRENCE, I WAS GOING TO TELL
YOU SOMETHING.
LOOK AT -- LOOK AT EVERYONE
LOVES LAWRENCE.
LAWRENCE IS A ROCK STAR.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
A TOTAL ROCK STAR.
>> Reporter: THEY SHOWED ME SO
MUCH LOVE.
LOOK AT ALL THESE PEOPLE RIGHT
HERE.
>> Sean: DO ME A FAVOR.
TURN AROUND AND SAYS SEAN
HANNITY SAYS I LOVE THEM AND
THANK THEM FOR KEEPING AMERICA
GREAT.
>> Reporter: SEAN HANNITY SAYS
HE LOVES YOU ALL AND THANKS FOR
KEEPING AMERICA GREAT.
[ CHEERS ]
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
I CAN'T BELIEVE WE PAY YOU TO DO
THIS.
WE PAY YOU TO DO THIS.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
BY THE WAY, LAWRENCE HAS THE
GREATEST PARENTS --
[ CROWD CHANTING "FOUR MORE
YEARS" ]